[Musique]
c'est le collège alsace corps et de
cilaos qui remporte cette sixième
édition du concours embellissement des
collèges un challenge qui récompense les
actions entreprises par les élèves pour
améliorer leur cadre de vie au sein de
leur établissement au moins on promet de
la valeur pour notre collège et
ça apporte beaucoup de liberté peut on
peut apprendre et au planton maillot
mais les noms des plans ce à chaque au
pied des blancs et ça a pris sa peau et
des élèves à comprendre c'est quoi la
l'embellissement ce n'est plus comme au
départ juste des bacs à fleurs qu'ont
fleuri on a pu fleurir avec dans l'est
dans les collèges maintenant c'est
devenu devrait paysagiste en herbe où il
est le moindre mètre carré est calculé
les espèces sont connus apprendre à
planter et comprendre l'importance du
végétal dans notre environnement c'est
aussi des objectifs portés par ceux
conclus cinq établissements ont été
récompensés pour leurs travaux paysage
qu'on a mis dix corps et des pas
japonais
et puis on a planté
avec l'arbre de vie pour les élèves les
seuls outrages quand il parle des lycées
la remise des prix s'est faite à mascara
un jardin botanique ou les lauréats du
concours ont planté plusieurs arbres
endémiques
[Musique]